it seemed like a normal Tuesday at the
head office of the athletic apparel
company DGS unbeknownst to most of the
employees however the company had just
been bought out by one of its
competitors and was now being forced to
accommodate a new internal structure
requiring several major cutbacks along
with many others Jess MacDonald employee
of four years would get let go this day
ever since Jess was a young teenager
she'd wanted to work for D GS
it was her favorite childhood company
she calculated her entire high school
college and early career decisions
according to this goal and now after
four years at the company she'd finally
started to establish a little seniority
and was beginning to move upwards not
enough to be one of the employees who
was kept but enough for it to sting
extra bad when she was fired on her last
day just left the office devastated by
the idea of needing to start over with
essentially no hope left for her working
at her dream company
she walks several city blocks to the bus
she took home which felt like the
longest and most shameful walk of her
life a few blocks from the bus stop
Jess found herself caught behind a small
group of people walking at an
infuriatingly slow speed Jess who
thought she was already walking slow
enough suddenly had to reduce her speed
a noticeable amount are you kidding me
how does an entire group of people walk
this slow just thought to herself within
a few steps just became almost sure that
the group was willfully ignoring her
presence behind them with no regard for
anyone other than themselves they were
as far as Jess was concerned entirely in
her way planted there to make her
already horrible day even worse finally
Jess impatiently squeezed her way
through the group bumping shoulders with
two of the individuals in the row as she
did she said excuse me
which sounded much more like get out of
my way than excuse me then she walked on
past them little to jest no one of the
two people she bumped shoulders with was
a young man named David who six months
prior had been diagnosed with early
onset amyotrophic lateral sclerosis also
known as ALS a terminal disease that
destroys the body's muscles by affecting
cells throughout the brain and spinal
cord David's family and friends were out
for a lunch and a walk with him he was
still early enough in the progression of
the disease to appear healthy but of
course David was walking slowly because
of this his ability to walk was the
first to start to go and David was now
forced to either take a wheelchair or
slowly and methodically when just plowed
through him in the small row of his
friends and family David immediately
became sad and ashamed reminded of the
fact that he was dying and becoming a
nuisance to others around him then he
thought about how inconsiderate and
selfish the woman was who bumped into
him and how the world appeared to be
playing a cruel joke on him which
quickly turned his sadness into anger
then when David's mom Cathy asked David
if he was okay and suggested that they
go home
David snapped at her he felt like his
mom babied and embarrassed him with no
ability to understand what he was going
through I only have a few years left mom
please stop ruining them David said to
her and an impulse of anger and weakness
of course this crushed David's mom but
because of David's own suffering and his
mom's attempt to be strong and not make
the situation about her David was not
properly aware of the magnitude of his
mom's suffering and how horribly this
affected her later that day first chance
she got David's mom stopped by the
liquor store she had been there a lot
recently while in line at the register
one of the four people in front of her
was an older man with a cart filled with
what looked to be at least thirty-five
bottles of various wines and liquors
requiring a huge obnoxious amount of
time for his transaction David's mom
looked at the old man with complete and
utter disdain thinking to herself who
buys this much alcohol at once a veteran
alcoholic stocking up for the month she
felt like the man was placed
specifically in her way to make her low
than the bright lights of the liquor
store sober and miserable then when the
man asked if he got the proper discount
on one of the two-for-one bottles
causing the cashier to need to go back
through the transaction David's mom was
sure he had no regard for her or anyone
else in line and said oh my god are you
serious soft enough for her to think it
might go unheard but loud enough for the
man
here it the man looked up and over to
her disgusted by her impatience the man
was in fact stocking up but for the wake
of one of his longtime best friends
would pass just a couple days prior the
man thought to himself how horribly
inconsiderate in nasty David's mom must
be to be so impatient over a couple
extra minutes then he thought of the
woman who cut him off on the way there
and then flipped them off when he honked
at her then he thought about how he was
the only one doing any of the work to
set up the funeral and prepare for the
wake of his friend he wondered why
everything was out to get him when the
man finally left a line and began
driving home on the way he passed
through a toll booth one that for some
reason still had a human in it the toll
was one dollar and fifty cents the old
man pulled up to the window and in a
state of exhausted anger and
inconsiderateness nearly threw the money
at the collector without looking at him
the collector had nothing particular
going wrong in his life at this moment
he was however just generally miserable
he was dealt a bad hand at birth and now
he spent his life in dead-end jobs
working in horrible monotony which by
this point had turned him rather bitter
and apathetic unpleasant experiences
like this were standard on the job and
didn't faze him at all in fact he
basically forgot about it as soon as the
next driver in line pulled up the toll
collector looked at the next driver with
dead eyes and said $1 50 the male driver
in the next car took a dollar from his
wallet and scrambled his car for 50
cents having not originally realized
that the toll was more than $1 the toll
collector visibly rolled his eyes and
audibly exhaled while the driver
frantically looked in the car
compartments that would normally have
changed then the collector said yeah
maybe next time ever ready huh [ __ ]
the driver looked up at the collector
and thought was wrong with you I should
beat the hella Defour talkin to me like
that the driver had just gotten in a
fight with his girlfriend and was fully
ready to take it out on someone
the driver imagined getting out of his
car and punching the collector in the
face then he thought to himself maybe
he's having a bad day maybe something's
wrong where something horrible has
happened to him recently maybe he's not
normally like this then the driver found
two quarters in the bottom section of
his car's front console and handed the
money to the collector I have a good
rest of the day man
the driver said sincerely nodding his
head with a slight smile before driving
off of course the driver was wrong it
was a normal day for the collector and
nothing was going any worse than any
other day even though the driver was
wrong the interaction costed him exactly
one dollar and fifty cents no more no
less
[Music]
[Music]
you